good morning and good afternoon
welcome to today's webinar titled tools
and methods for crispr cast mine
screening
for functional genomics and drug
discovery our presenter today is louise
baskin
senior product manager for functional
genomics at thermal fissure scientific
my name is matt pulling also thermal
fissure scientific and i'll be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational webinar is brought
to you by lab roots and sponsored by in
vitrogen by thermo fisher scientific
and petrogen offers tools and solutions
for every step in the crispr genome
editing workflow for more information
please visit us at www.thermofisher.com
crispr i would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time during the presentation to
do so
simply type them in the ask a question
box and click the send button
a portion of these questions will be
answered live by luis
following the presentation and all
questions that we don't respond to
during the live session
will receive a written response you will
see multiple tabs across the top of the
page
please feel free to click through our
related applications upcoming and
on-demand webinars as well as links to
in vitrogen crispr cast 9 webpages
also please notice that you can share
your webinar on your personal social
media
just click the social sharing tab to let
your friends and colleagues know about
today's live event
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box
located to the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
offers continuing education credits
please click through the continuing
education credit tab located at the top
right of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i'd like to now introduce our presenter
louise baskin
luis has 15 years of experience in
product management marketing and
technical sales of reagents and tools
for gene modulation
encompassing rna interference and crispr
cas9
she is responsible for managing the
thermo fisher portfolio sir a
custom rna synthesis and crispr guide
rna products
she received a master's degree in
molecular biology and genetics
from northwestern university and with
that louis i will hand it over to you
good morning and good afternoon everyone
thank you for joining today
i'm i'm sure many of you are growing
tired of looking at computer screens but
hopefully you will extract some value in
the time we spend today
discussing tools and methods for crispr
screening for
functional genomics and drug discovery
now it's it's i'm sure many of you
already know something about thermo
fisher scientific i'm not going to spend
a lot of time
about who we are and what we do but i do
want to
mention our company's mission statement
enabling our customers to make the world
healthier cleaner and safer
for me this has recently taken on a
whole new meaning as we
kind of navigate this kobit 19 landscape
both kind of in my own stay-at-home life
as well as in appreciating my company's
contributions
to the pandemic response um with
instruments
consumables safety supplies and most
importantly diagnostic tests
um you know staying healthy clean and
safe has really never been so important
as it is now
and hopefully you're joining today
because you you know see the potential
of functional genomics
as a way to make progress you know
towards your own mission
so what i hope to provide today is
insight
from you know my corner of the thermo
world to help in advancing your research
i'll do a brief overview of the role of
crispr cast 9 for functional genomics
and how it's used to carry out lots of
function studies i'll next review the
available crispr
reagent types with a quick overview of
considerations for choosing each type
and i'll cover our guide rna algorithm
development and its validation
and then i'll spend time sharing details
about our lentiviral guide rna libraries
and then get into applications with
those libraries you know really showing
them in action
i'll share the workflow from a pilot
screen we carried out to look at pathway
analysis
and i'll close with results from a
kinase screen library
being used for drug discovery
using functional genomics researchers
gain an understanding of how
a change in a gene's expression level
whether that's one gene or many will
give rise to changes in a cell's
phenotype
for for kind of foundational or basic
research the purpose might be to
determine
a gene's role in a particular biological
pathway or process
you know in other settings maybe like in
a biotech or pharma
we see functional genomics being used to
identify a potential druggable target
so my talk today i'll walk through
examples of each of these types of
investigations
specific to the type of functional
genomics i'm talking about are
loss of function studies where in
essence we're reducing the expression of
individual genes and looking for changes
in the cellular phenotype
for research studies these typically are
going to rely on
cell-based phenotypes to you know just
give us kind of a slice of biological
information
about the role that genes play in our
system of interest
the tool sets that are most commonly
used for loss of function
are rna interference or rnai where we
can knock down
expression at the mrna level or using
crispr cast 9 to completely knock
out expression now thermo has excellent
tools in both of these areas but today's
topic is going to be focused on
crispr knockout so like most good
presentations i'm going to start with a
brief review of the
biology so crispr cas9 mediated gene
editing
is part of a bacterial immune response
and strep pyogenes which is the most
widely adopted system
for mammalian gene editing small rnas
called crispr rnas
are transcribed they have a 20
nucleotide
unique spacer derived region and a 22
nucleotide conserved repeat derived
region
separately a long rna called tracer rna
is also transcribed and the crispr and
the tracer rna
hybridized through the repeat derived
sequence and this crispr tracer hybrid
is collectively known as the guide rna
it can then recruit the cas9
endonuclease which is shown
in my figure in green and this cat9
complex then
uses the unique spacer derived sequence
as a guide to its dna target
which is a region that's always going to
be immediately proximal to a three
nucleotide protospacer adjacent motif or
pam
so for s-pyogenes this motif is ngg
so the genomic dna is then pleased by
the cas9
nucleus just adjacent to that pamphlet
and again in s-pyogenes this is an
immune response mechanism
that's used to defend against foreign
genetic material
but a number of years ago it was adapted
for use in mammalian cells and animal
models for
targeted genomic cleavage
so how are researchers using this
technology for functional genomics
when we create double strand breaks in
the genome the cell's innate repair
mechanism kicks in
for a straight up repair of a break the
mechanism is typically going to be
non-homologous
end joining or nhej and the thing about
nhej is that it's not always perfect
it is just as likely to introduce errors
such as insertions or deletions
you'll see me later collectively called
these indels um
while it's in the process of trying to
stitch everything back together
so when we use crispr cast 9 to
deliberately target
the coding sequence of a protein this
imperfect repair can lead to
a frame shift a nonsense mutation or a
premature stop codon
and knock out functional expression of
the gene so there can still be
functional wild-type protein expressed
if the break is repaired
but improvement in the design of guide
rnas which i'll discuss in a few slides
has really helped to kind of tip the
scales towards that imperfect repair so
that we get a higher rate of knockout
and there are a lot of other
applications for genome engineering
using these targeted nucleuses um
knock-ins or other precise editing but
for today i'm just focusing on
the application of functional knockouts
so for
being able to do those lots of function
studies
so i want to take a minute and look
closer at the two components that are
needed
for doing a knockout experiment with
crispr again this isn't an endogenous
mechanism so both of those components
need to be introduced into our cells of
interest the cas9 nuclease
and the guide rna both of which need to
be expressed
or delivered at high efficiency to
achieve robust editing
so i'm going to take a quick walk
through both of these components
so first is the cas9 nucleus which can
take many forms i'm showing two of them
here on the screen
listed with the name of the reagent as
it's available from in vitrogen
the earliest days of crispr mostly
utilized cas9 express from a plasmid
but that quickly fell out of favor
mostly for reasons of efficiency
so both protein and mrna shown here on
the screen
offer dna free expression of cat9
so if you're engineering a cell line
you're not going to have residual
casino expression or any kind of genomic
incorporation as you might have
with a plasmid both of these can be
easily co-transfected or
co-electroporated
along with a synthetic guide rna when
cells
are amenable to that delivery cas9
protein
ours is called truecut casting protein
v2
has really emerged as the most popular
format for both knockout and not
in experiments due to the ability to
complex it with a guide rna
to form kind of a ready-to-go
ribonuclear complex or rnp
because there's no transcription or
translation required
the entire complex is ready to go as
soon as you deliver it
the other popular method for cas9
expression in cells is to express it
from a lentiviral vector
this gives you the benefit of enriching
the transduced population because you
can also co-express
an antibiotic resistance marker you also
have the option of using an inducible
promoter
to turn on cas9 expression at a
particular time point
and then you also have the advantage of
working in a wide range of cell types
you know even those that might be really
difficult to transfect
because lentiviral transduction can
generally be successful in a very wide
range of cell types
so for the applications i'll talk about
today the main advantage to length of
broadcast nine
is being able to create cas9 stably
expressing cells
this approach is optimal for
experimental setups like high throughput
screenings that i'll be talking about
today
or even any situation where a cell line
of interest is going to be used over and
over again
for crispr studies it creates a nice
stable background of cast iron
expression so you can focus
just on delivery of the guide rna
the guide rnas also come in multiple
formats to support a
range of workflows synthetic single
guide rnas or sdrnas
are where the crispr and the tracer are
catenated into a single
long rna and these are most popular with
systems that can support that rnp
delivery where you complex the guide
with the casino protein and deliver
either by
transfection or electroporation
the in vitrogen truguide sgrnas
incorporate three prime and five prime
chemical modifications that enhance
stability
and these modified guides have
demonstrated higher efficiency in a
number of
experimental systems and cell types
synthetic guides can also be easily
transfected into cast iron expressing
cells
and again sensitive transient they're
very suitable for knock out as well as
knock in
gene editing where you don't want any
residual crisper components left behind
as with the cas9 nucleus there's also a
lentiviral option for expression of
guide rnas
from our company these are known as
lenti-array guides
these are delivered as high tide or
lentiviral particles
selection markers can be utilized you
know in ours and
as well as any platform and again this
is a way to be able to enrich the
population of transduced cells
the guys can be delivered into cast 9
expressing cells or co-transduced
with lentiviral cas9 in a single
delivery step
and again you have that advantage of
being able to work in cell types that
are difficult to transfect
due to that ability of transduction into
a wide range of cells
as we developed our guide rna product
lines we also spent a lot of time and
effort on our algorithm
to find the most efficient guide rna
sequences
so i'm just going to show you a very
high level overview of how we accomplish
this
so first we identified target loci where
the indel formation would result in
editing of
all isoforms so in most cases this is
done by
targeting conserved exons typically in
the five prime end
since it has been shown that indels
formed in the in the earlier part of the
transcript
are going to have a better likelihood of
causing functional knockouts
next we identify all available guide
rnas in that conserved region
based on the presence of that pam site
so the ndg motif
that is required for the guide rna
recognition
and then we looked at all of the guide
designs and scored them
based on functionality and expected
binding efficiency to cast nine
so there's a number of target sequence
characteristics that contribute to this
such as sequence complexity gc content
whether certain bases are in certain
positions along the guide
um there is a lot of data that
demonstrates there's certain base
positions that can improve efficiency we
also give preference to certain
ndg motifs over others it has been shown
that some can be
more active
so for those remaining guides that that
scored well in functionality we then
take and score them based on sequence
specificity
so we had done our work to decide if we
thought they'd be efficient but now we
need to make sure they're not also going
to target
other regions of the genome so we
analyze potential
off-target size sites based on sequence
matches to different regions of the
genome
but there's different levels of
tolerance for different types of
sequence similarity
so examples of similarities that could
be tolerated are shown
here with green check marks if there's
multiple mismatches in the seed region
which is the portion
closest to the pan site this is the most
critical for guide rna recognition
of that genomic site or if that off
target site lacks the presence of a pam
these are going to be you know pretty
much tolerated by our specificity score
because they're not
likely to to cleave in that off-target
site
but if there are perfect matches or even
just perfect matches in the seed region
shown as the examples with the red x's
these types of mismatches have shown the
ability to still engage in cleavage
events
and so therefore would be considered off
targets so so these guides
would be discarded as being too
non-specific
and then out of those remaining we
choose our top four non-overlapping
guides
for everything that's designed against a
certain gene and then offer them
as pre-designed guide rna reagents
so this is a measure of the cleavage
efficiency for those top four designs
targeting 18 different genes so here we
delivered
true guide synthetic sdrnas into cas9
expressing cells
and then analyzed cleavage efficiency
and you can see we got greater than 60
percent on average
and and this is from a genomic cleavage
assay that can often under represent
total editing
so the algorithm is really doing a good
job in determining guides that have
high efficiency
did some additional validation
experiments uh using our lentiarate
products
uh not just to see how well they knocked
down but see how well they worked in an
array format
so in this case we did an assessment
with a dual transduction
so delivering cas9 and lengthy viral
crispr guide rnas at the same time
we targeted eight different genes in an
arrayed format
following pure myosin selection for five
days we used
again that genomic cleavage detection
essay to assess
editing so these gels show the results
from that
genomic cleavage assay and then they're
quantified on the bar graph on the right
and really
as you can see demonstrated very high
efficiency in dell formation
so these results really was part of what
encouraged us to pursue an arrayed
library product format
with the lengthy array guide rna product
line
as we did the build out of those
libraries we did more experiments to
look at our efficiency so
here's a set of results targeting 155
genes that are part of the lenti array
human cancer biology library
so we did these experiments at two
different moi or multiplicity of
infection
if you're unfamiliar with this that is
the ratio of the number of viral
particles to the number of cells
you can say that in the upper graph at
an moi of one
77 percent of the targets achieved 50
percent or
greater editing efficiency and this time
we're asking
using next-gen sequencing instead of
genomic cleavage
at the higher moi in the lower graph we
had 87 percent of targets at or above
that that 50
cutoff if we set the bar even higher
the moi of one has over half of the
guides at 70 percent or better editing
and the moif-10 still looks really good
with 77
achieving that 70 or better editing
efficiency so now i'm going to shift
into a little more of the technical
details of the
arrayed lentiviral crispr libraries
so many in the screening world have
readily acknowledged the utility of
crispr knockout
for loss of function studies given that
we can achieve
complete permanent knockout of gene
expression and not just partial
silencing
it gives us more robust phenotypes and
therefore a much larger assay window
leading to then higher confidence in our
heads and better hit confirmation
so when you talk about functional
genomic screening there's always a need
to discuss both strategies both pooled
and arranged screening so most of the
talk is going to focus on a raid
screening today but i don't want to
ignore
pools completely given that they're a
great product
and most pooled screens end up
eventually as an array screen
because you do need to look at the
individual guys rnas in doing
hit confirmation from a primary screen
so i've listed on the slide what i what
i've always thought are the biggest
differentiators
between these two approaches although
others certainly do exist
and i think it's worth mentioning
neither one of these is better
than the other you know it's really
about educating yourself on these
distinctions to determine which format
is best
for your particular experiment in your
particular essay
so a pooled library contains lentiviral
guide rnas targeting
all of your genes in a single tube and
the transduction into your cells will
take place in one or very few
large dishes so the need for liquid
handling or any other kind of robotic
infrastructure is pretty low
a raid screening where each guide or
maybe a pool of multiple guides is
arranged in a one gene per well format
this is potentially going to require a
lot more infrastructure for
dispensing of reagents into tens or
hundreds of plates
but the biggest differentiator between
the two from a scientific point of view
is the type of assay that can be
supported
pooled screening requires a somewhat
basic sort of yes no assay
you know viability or survival that
separates life from dead potentially
upon treatment with
a drug or some other um sort of survival
pressure
or you can use a facts analysis readout
to separate
you know a green from non-green in a
reporter assay
in contrast a raid screening lets you go
well beyond viability
into high content assays for cell
morphology translocation
migration assays nuclear alterations
really anything that can be visualized
under a microscope there's also much
more ability to look at
quantitative loss of function results
since you can actually rank the hits by
the degree of
intensity or penetrance that's measured
in each well
so in support of both of these
strategies we have
lentipool v2 crispr libraries
which include four guide rnas per gene
that are delivered
to you as high tide or virus as of 1
times 10 to the 8th
all of our pools go through extensive
quality control to ensure
guide rna representation those same
lentiviral guides are also available in
an array format
so to support high throughput studies we
do pool the four guides purging into a
single well
this is a great method for reducing the
number of plates required for your
screen and still get really good
efficient editing of your target
each lenti array library is delivered as
two aliquots the 50 microliters each
again at a titer of one times ten to the
eighth in addition
to lentiviral particles we offer the
individual lengthy rate guides as
glycerol stocks
so you have a renewable resource of
guides for making your own libraries or
using for
follow-up studies regardless of the
format all of our crispr libraries are
available as
19 different genes family libraries like
kinases or gpcrs
or they are arranged by function like
epigenetics or cancer biology
and we also have whole genome
collections for doing you know really
completely unbiased investigations
so in support of pilot studies or doing
follow-up or any groups that have their
own list of important genes
we can also assemble any of these
formats into a custom collection
that suits your needs
so to show you a bit more about the
vectors in the in our lengthy viral
products
so the lentireicas9 nuclease shown here
on the left
encodes a human codon-optimized
s-pyogenes cas9 protein
with two nuclear localization signals
cas9 and blastocytin resistance are both
driven off an efs
or short ef1 alpha promoter
the lenti ray guide rna expresses a
specific
guide rna from a u6 promoter while the
pure myson resistance gene is separately
driven again by an efs promoter
all of these contracts constructs are
sequence verified following production
and as you'll see in my examples coming
up they can be used either transiently
or with selection from pure mice and
treatment to enrich
for the population that has received the
guides
and here's a look at our lenti array
controls so as most screeners know
or will quickly find out the key to a
good screen
is optimization both of the delivery of
the guide rnas as well as the assay
readout
so using these validated controls gives
you egsp expression
as a visual readout of transduction
efficiency it's a really
nice straightforward visual tool to help
optimize transduction
to determine the appropriate moi there's
two different lengthy array controls we
have a non-targeting control
which of course should target nowhere in
the genome but provides a nice control
for non-specific effects
because of the transduction and then any
subsequent treatment treatments required
for the phenotypic assay for a knockout
positive control we target the hprt gene
which can be used to estimate
the overall efficiency of editing but
you can also use this gene
as a knockout as a phenotypic negative
control because
generally speaking hprt silencing or
knockout will be inert
in most biological pathways you can use
as a positive control for knockout and
potentially a negative control
in your phenotypic assay
so now i've touched on the technical
aspects of the lentirae guide rnas i'm
going to go into those two different
case studies
that show these arrayed libraries in
action
so at a high level these are the steps
i'm going to take to
take you through our pilot study
workflow we established a cas9
expressing cell line we optimized our
transduction and assay conditions
set up our plates and controls to run
the screen and then
i went through a series of steps for hit
confirmation
so the data i'm showing you is from an
in-house pilot study
but a much larger screen using the same
essay has recently been submitted for
publications
by our collaborators at astrazeneca
so first step is to generate that stable
casing expressing
cell line so as i said before
constitutive
cas9 expression is recommended for high
throughput studies
so starting with our cells of interest
we transduced with the lentiviral cas9
following an antibiotic kill curve we
treated with appropriate amount of
blastocytin
did selection for about three weeks and
then carried out clonal isolation
we then expanded those cells to verify
and characterize functional casine
expression
so in the lower left you'll see our
results with a western blot
where those alpha numeric labels are
different clonal isolates
with beta action as a loading control we
looked at
expression of cas9 and saw a really good
expression of cas9 in all of these
clones
on the right you'll see some of those
same clones analyzed now for cleavage
deficiency
upon treatment with the guide rna using
that positive control targeting hprt
now you'll notice that there is some
variation in the cleavage results
between the different clones which isn't
necessarily
you know kind of visually represented uh
in the western blot for the cast 9
presence but what this does to me is it
illustrates the importance of
ensuring that your clonal lines are not
just assessed for cas9 expression
but also for the degree of functional
efficiency you can see
so our goal in selecting a clone to to
expand and use for
our our studies is to have the best
cleavage
along with demonstration of similar
growth rates and morphology as the
parental cell line
so the cells that we use for this study
are one of the cell
sensor cell lines these are engineered
for the study of various biological
pathways
through analysis of signal transduction
now there are
a few dozen cell sensor lines available
they're
for analysis of different pathways and
they're derived from different cell
types
but what they all have in common is the
use of this reporter system
to determine pathway activity through
beta-lactamase activation
so the dla substrate is a coumarin-like
molecule shown on the left
that can be excited by uv light and it's
linked
to a fluorescein or a 50-like molecule
that emits green when it's excited so
these are connected by a beta-lactam
ring shown in red
so when a pathway of interest gets
activated
beta lactamase is expressed which
cleaves that beta lactame ring
that then results in an altered
fluorophore such that
when excited by uv light it now emits
blue
since the energy isn't able to be
transferred to the green fluorophore
so what this all comes down to is a nice
measurable method
of determining the levels of
beta-lactamase expression
so let's look at this assay in action
for the screen that we carried out we're
looking at
nf kappa b activation when we treat the
cells with tnf alpha
this triggers a signal cascade for
activation of nf kappa b
which translocates into the nucleus and
triggers the expression of
beta-lactamase
so here's where that bla substrate comes
in in the absence of beta-lactamase
we get green emission so without
tnf-alpha cells are green
but when tnf-alpha is added to the cells
the nf kappa b
is activated beta lactamase is expressed
and the cells become blue
so our plan for our first pilot study
was to treat these cells
with a number of lenti array guide rnas
targeting genes in that nf kappa b
activation pathway
and then see how effectively we could
block the green the blue change in the
presence of the tnf
alpha activator
but before we get to the guides
themselves first things first we need to
make sure we're working with optimal
transduction conditions
so delivery of guide rnas whether you're
using lengthy braille transduction or a
transfection agent
is a very important step to optimize to
make sure you get the maximum
efficiency of editing so the two
variables we worked with
were the cell density and the moi of the
viral particles
we tested two different cell densities
at four different mois in a 384-wheel
plate
delivering guide rnas targeting hprt as
a negative control
since i mentioned it's it's not a gene
that plays a role uh in this particular
pathway of interest
we also looked at t-rad which is a gene
within that nf-kappab
signaling pathway and then we also
targeted beta-lactamase itself as our
reporter molecule
so knockdown of t-red and beta-lactamase
gives us a decrease
in the percent activation compared to
the hprt control
so what we're looking for is conditions
that give us virtually no effect in hprt
knockout
but the greatest effect with t-red and
beta-lactamase
at the lowest moi so you can see we got
good separation
of the positive and negative controls
specifically if you look at the blue
bars representing an moi of two
this is the condition that best meets
our criteria so we went with that amount
of
the guide rna for the screen and then
found really that we could use either
cell density
and get pretty similar results so we
used the lower amount of cells
we also tested whether we needed to do
pure mycin selection
to give us the best separation of hits
from non-hits
along with establishing an optimal time
point so we looked at day five
and day nine post transduction both with
and without pure mice and selection
you can see in comparing those red and
blue bars that there's little need for
doing selection we had really great
penetrance from the knockout without it
so while we knew we could use it it was
really unnecessary
and we also found that we could easily
read the assay by day five
so that was what we went with in all of
our subsequent experiments
so now we're ready to run our pilot we
used our stable
cas9 cell sensor line with our optimized
conditions we transduced
lentirate guide rnas targeting genes
known to be either positive or negative
in this assay
four days later we added alpha and then
took our measurements of the readout
so as expected in the absence of tnf
alpha our cells remained green for cells
that were treated with tnf alpha
are negative controls which in this case
you can see is a non-targeting control
or that hprt
targeting guide rna we see very
effective conversion of green to blue
indicating the nf-kappab pathway was
activated and beta-lactamase was
efficiently expressed
but when we look at genes within that nf
kappa b pathway
um we see that in including our positive
controls of targeting beta-lactamase
itself
we see really effective inhibition of
the assay readout
uh demonstrating really again now
efficient knockout
of that target in virtually every cell
um
and keep in mind this was without any
antibiotic selection
for enrichment of those cells
so even though the visual results were
pretty convincing we
followed best practice to verify that
our results were due to actual editing
at the
indicated genomic position so this first
figure is just
a quantification of the nf kappa b
inhibition that we observed
so just like visually you see lots of
green cells you can see by quantifying
this we saw 80 to 90 percent
effective inhibition of the pathway uh
for the t-red and ikk alpha
knockout then we did next-gen sequencing
to look at actual indel formation by
those two guide rnas
as you can see we had over 95 genomic
editing with t-rad
and 85 with ikk alpha so excellent
correlation
of that knockout with the phenotypic
penetrance
we then expanded those cells for 14 days
to get enough to run
a western blot to look at protein levels
so for untreated cells we had very
strong bands for both
target proteins and the knockout cells
as expected and very nice to see there's
clearly no band that's visible
so even at this point we were pretty
certain that our results were real
you know the knockout of the target gene
was effectively blocking nf kappa
deactivation
we did one more verification on these
hits and this time
stepping away from the beta-lactamase
reporter system completely
and just looking at nf kappa b itself so
we know that in the presence of pnf
alpha and if kappa b will activate
and translocate to the nucleus so in
untreated cells that's exactly what we
see here
we see green cytoplasmic and f kappa b
in the upper panel
and upon treatment with tnf alpha it
becomes nuclear
in the lower panel but in our trad and
ikk alpha knockout
it's very clear that this pathway is
being disrupted as shown by the lack of
the green
nuclear nf kappa b and the presence of
tnf alpha in those lower panels
so this type of orthogonal verification
is really essential
to any kind of hit analysis following a
screen
so our conclusions from this pilot study
were really very encouraging
we had highly penetrant robust
phenotypes and we were able to
accomplish this without the requirement
of enriching with selection markers we
had excellent efficiency of knockout as
measured at the genomic level and this
knockout
showed really good correlation with our
cellular phenotypes
and then lastly our strong hits were
very easily verified
with orthogonal assays
the last section of my talk today is to
review some really promising results
from a collaborator who used
the valencia array libraries to do
crispr screening for drug discovery
so this is a published example of an
early beta tester who was working with
the lenti ray library to find potential
therapeutic targets
dr simone sredney is a pathologist at
lurie's children's hospital in chicago
and dr shredney studies a pediatric
cancer called malignant rhabdoid tumor
or
mrt this is a universally lethal disease
it's rare only about 60 infants per year
are diagnosed
but it is the most frequent cause of
tumors in infants under six months of
age
90 of the cases occur in children under
three years of age so really as you can
imagine a really horrible prognosis
being a pathologist dr shredney has a
collection of cell and tissue samples
that she's used in her research to try
to identify potential new therapeutic
targets for this patient population that
has
a very urgent need however using
traditional gene expression techniques
she has not yet identified she had not
yet identified any potential targets
now about three years ago dr shreddy
participated in our beta test program
and we provided her with the lentiarate
guide rna
library targeting 160 gene targets
from the human kinases
so i'm not going to repeat all of the
optimization steps
that were essentially the same as what i
showed in our pilot study
but i do want to hit a lot of the
highlights of this screen so she
utilized
moan cells which were established from a
patient rhabdoid tumor tissue
the upper figure here is from the
transduction optimization
using gfp expressing control guide rna
you can see generally these cells
exhibited very high transfection
transduction efficiency moon cells that
stably express cas9 were generated
and in this case they worked with the
stably expressing population
rather than go through those steps for
clonal selection
and and clonal characterization these
moan cas9 cells were transduced
in 96 well dishes with guide rnase
targeting 160 different kinases
and then expanded under selection for
seven days
cells were then transferred in equal
numbers to 12 well plates
and the time to reach confluence was
measured so the goal of the screen is to
identify genes
that when knocked out would slow the
growth of patient-derived mrt
cells following all that number of
divisions
so this pie chart shows the distribution
of that proliferation assay result for
all 160 genes and the controls
this is this is relevant to therapeutic
development in the sense that
slower growth of a tumor means more time
for chemotherapy or other anti-tumor
treatments to take hold
so 70 percent of the genes studied
reached confluence in seven to ten days
a smaller subset took a bit longer 11 to
12 days
but the genes of highest interest to
this team were the eight kinases that
when they were knocked out took at least
14 days to reach
confluence tlk4 which was the top hit
took 22 days so how important is plk4 in
these cells
this gene had not come up in any prior
studies using differential expression
analysis
but in normal brain tissue or
non-embryonal brain
tumor tissues compared to brain tumors
there is no there is excuse me if there
is significant difference
in plk4 expression levels both when
measured
by microarray analysis shown in the
figure on the left
or by qpcr shown on the right this
differential expression
really strengthens the case for pok4 as
a relevant target
in these embryonic brain tumors
dr shredney then further demonstrated
that
knockout of plk4 resulted in significant
reduction
of a marker for cell proliferation ki-67
um you can see that above
in the production the dark red color in
the cell image
which is then quantified in the bar
graph again showing a significant
difference between
uh the mooncas9 cells with and without
the plk4
rna furthermore knockout of plk4
also reduced the malignant tendencies of
the cells
as shown by this clonogenic assay those
cells again with the plk4 knockout
compared to the
the untreated cas9 moan cells had a
reduced capacity to generate
colony-forming units
the team then stepped away from crispr
cas9 and went on to test
a compound a specific plk4 inhibitor
cfi 400 945 to see if the effects could
be repeated
this is a very common follow-up strategy
for lots of function screens using
crispr
to look for orthogonal results using
sirna or a known chemical inhibitor of
your target gene
so here i'm showing you that they got
very similar responses in that
clonogenic assay
not just in the moon cells but also in
three other cancers
you can see the very significant impact
on the ability of these cells to
generate those colony forming units when
they're treated with the plk4 inhibitor
later that same year dr shredney pushed
this work even further and published
a follow-up paper to further validate
these findings this time using an animal
model
of mrt so as part of this study
they created a xenograft model using
nude mice
and injecting patient mrt cells into
their brains to establish tumors
the mice were then treated with that
same plk4 inhibitor cfi 400 945
and it was found to reduce the size of
the tumors and extend the life
of those mice so these very encouraging
results took
dr shreddy and her team to the next
logical step which was to look at how to
leverage this
as a potential anti-cancer treatment in
patients
so late last year dr shredney and her
team published these results
of an evaluation looking at a wider
range of inhibitors
in a clinical model of embryonal tumors
so the study's goal was to understand
the potential of available pok4
inhibitors
for treatment of these rhabdoid tumors
although they had
mouse model data showing that you know
that one of these molecules was
effective
there's much more work that needs to be
done to determine a compound suitability
for use in humans especially if it
requires crossing the blood-brain
barrier
so the authors evaluated eight different
pki or protein kinase inhibitor
compounds
in a pre-clinical model with regard to
their
anti-cancer properties and potential for
brain exposure
i've put a few of the example assays
that i used to assess
or score these these different molecules
they looked at docking selectivity in
the catalytic domain of pok4
they looked at the bbb permeability
index which is a way to measure the
capability to penetrate the blood brain
barrier
and then also looked at inhibition of
kinase activity
and in doing these acids they looked not
just at the pok4 target
but they looked at a much wider range of
kinases to determine potential
for cross reactivity now i'm not going
to get into any of these analyses in any
depth it would simply take too long and
it's really
kind of getting too far a field of
functional genomics but i do want to
show just one figure
from this paper that's a familiar assay
from what we just looked at
so here you see that same colony forming
assay as we saw in the initial screening
paper
this time used across five embryonal
tumor cell lines
with three of the eight compounds that
were being assessed so in each data set
the cells on the left are untreated and
the cells on the right are treated with
a corresponding
inhibitor as you can see the first two
compounds were affected in some cell
types but not all
whereas cf5400 437 on the right
had pretty complete inhibition of colony
formation in all five tumor lines
now as i said a minute ago a deep dive
here just is not possible i'm i'm going
to go right to their submarine
conclusions and if you're curious i
really encourage you to look more at
this paper
i certainly learned a lot from it um so
although my previous slide made it look
like
cfi 400 437 might be a good candidate
it as well as the compound looked at in
that mouse model
turned out to not be optimal for brain
exposure in doing those permeability
tests
and and all the others tested had
shortcomings as well either
poor activity with good brain
penetration or vice versa
so the authors were able to conclude
that a selective plk4 inhibitor
with favorable brain exposure properties
could definitely be beneficial for the
treatment of these
brain tumors that show plk for over
expression
they also concluded the the strong need
to improve the existing inhibitors
for better selectivity and brain
exposure or to
develop new ones that have these desired
characteristics
so in essence they didn't find a silver
bullet but they do still believe plk4 to
be a valid target
for these embryonic brain tumors
now just to close up on this particular
story i borrowed this slide from one of
the r d scientists in our group who
presented this paper at a journal club
and i i felt like it nicely captured not
just the extent of the work required
following target identification
it also shows the degree to which uh the
thermo fisher scientific products and
services that are
shown in blue were able to play a part
in these efforts that go well beyond
that initial lenti array screen
the scientists illustrated these as
lanterns kind of helping to light the
way along this path
and i feel like this visual kind of
helped bring things full circle back to
thermal's mission of helping our
customers to make the world healthier
cleaner and safer
and seeing this story come this far
certainly you know gives me hope you
know when i'm able to see it go beyond a
functional genomic screen
and and into the space where we can
truly see a therapeutic benefit
so i hope you've taken away something
useful from today's session
i stayed away from a deep dive on the
entire portfolio
but hopefully gave you an idea of the
breadth of tools available
to you from thermo for crispr cast 9 to
meet
virtually any experimental need from the
examples i've shown you hopefully
appreciate the power of functional
genomic screening as a method
for discovery but also came away with
the importance of proper optimization
and use of controls for reproducible
results
and then lastly how the lenti ray crispr
libraries are effective
high throughput loss of function
screening tools for pathway analysis
and drug discovery and so with that i'll
thank you again for joining take any
questions that have come in
and turn it over to matt for those
questions
thank you very much that was great we
had a lot of questions come in so we'll
get right to those if you still have a
question
that you'd like to ask please do so now
just click the ask a question box
located in the far left side of your
screen
our first question came in kind of early
in the presentation so you might have
already addressed this but
why should one use lentiviral guides
instead of synthetic guides
oh sure um there is a slide on this but
yeah sometimes these come in before
we get to it um and it really is very
often going to be a matter of which one
is a better fit for your experiment
but also preference can play in that as
well so
both the lenti ray and the true guide
synthetic guides will give good knockout
right they're designed with the same
algorithm synthetic guides
and delivered with cas9 protein is
really optimal for experiments
where you want the crisper components to
be transient in the cell where you
you don't want any ongoing expression of
the guide and there's no need to do any
kind of selection
or enrichment of the edited cells
that that transient approach is also
really optimal
if you're creating an engineered cell
line because you don't want any again
you don't want that residual
components in the cell the the
lentiviral guys give you that additional
advantage of being
self-delivering um you know there's no
transfection agents needed
they can be used very often in cells
that are otherwise resistant to
transfection reagents
and then of course they have the the use
of those antibiotic resistance markers
to do the enrichment
um and both formats can be used in in an
arrayed uh you know layout for screening
so really
you just kind of need to do a checklist
of your sales characteristics you know
your essay requirements and your own
experimental goals to kind of determine
the best option
awesome thank you um
why don't the lenti array guys express
gfp so that there's a visual indication
of their delivery
oh right i gosh i might not have said
this in the presentation
so we we deliberately chose not to
express gfp
or or any fluorophore on the guides
really due to the potential for
interference in reporter essays
or you know any other reason you might
have stably expressed fluorophores in
your cells
we we wanted to make sure that
researchers had all available channels
open for their experiments so you can
imagine
if you think about that nf kappa b assay
anything green or blue that was
expressing from the guide rna
would have made it impossible to use
that reporter system um
we do as i as i showed have the gfp on
our controls
so they can still be used like on every
plate during a screen or during
that optimization phase to help identify
the best conditions
but there's nothing being expressed that
will get in the way of
the actual screen
awesome thank you uh next question we
have
here is is it required to do clonal
isolation when making
your cast 9 expressing cell line
yeah and and i showed examples of both
doing clonal and using a population i i
think it's still kind of a mixed bag in
terms of
you know opinions and results of using
kind of that parental
or mixed cell line versus doing clonal
isolation
so one school of thought is that
expression is more consistent and can be
monitored more easily
when you're working with a clonal line
so once you've characterized it you can
very easily monitor
changes but on the flip side
a mixed population kind of gives you the
advantage of no
single incorporation event being the
same in every cell
so any possible bias from you know
disruption in the genome
is going to be diluted out i've also
heard
that not all cell types are amenable to
you know kind of the
the isolation and the steps required for
doing clonal cell lines
um so obviously you need to do what
keeps yourself happy and if that means
keeping them kind of in a heterogeneous
mix and you do
honestly i've seen publications and
excellent results with both
so i think it matters kind of how much
you want to utilize
that castline version of your cells over
time um
and you know kind of your comfort level
with with potentially heterogeneous
levels of casino and expression from
from cell to cell
awesome um next question we had here is
uh
what kind of stability data do we have
on the lentiviral
guides oh um
we have data showing out to three years
so far with no loss in tighter this of
course is using all the
recommended you know storage uh
conditions of keeping them at minus 80.
we haven't gone further out than that
yet time wise
really because the product isn't old
enough
as with any lentiviral particles the
biggest
risk to stability or really maintaining
that functional titer is avoiding freeze
thaws
so for instance with the library that we
deliver we do that in two aliquots of 50
microliters
and the recommendation is to make
daughter plates immediately
upon arrival so that you only need to
take them out of the freezer when it's
time to do your screen and the and the
others can
uh can stay happy and frozen
awesome thank you uh next question
here oops matt just clicked away for a
second um
you said that people will use sir a as a
follow-up for
the screening results um could you
elaborate on this a little bit more are
srnas the best tool for for this
particular follow-up
yeah and and sometimes it's not about
best it's about
if if you have a knockout result
that you have reason to believe results
in an interesting phenotype
it's nice to step away from kind of that
crispr cas9 system and say
are there other ways i can induce a loss
of function in these cells
to to verify these results and make sure
it's not you know some element of crispr
somehow you know that might be causing
it
so srna is a kind of tried and true way
of
knocking down uh gene expression you
know at the mrna level
so by moving from crispr cas9 to srna
you now are working at the mrna level
instead of at the genome level um you
know you're stepping away from anything
involving a nuclease
so you can have kind of an orthogonal
loss of function system
um so if the srna result agrees with
your crispr knockout result
you can feel pretty confident that
the result you're seeing you know the
phenotype you're seeing is because you
have reduced that gene's expression
um but with that being said it is
entirely possible as well
that those results might not agree now
that does not mean that it's not a real
result
it might mean that the phenotype you saw
for instance
required complete knockout whereas we
know that
rnai leaves some residual level of
expression
and maybe that wasn't enough to push
towards your phenotype so
that doesn't mean the hit isn't real it
just might mean that srna wasn't the
right tool
for that particular validation but when
they do agree
it's a pretty good data point to have to
show that different ways of loss of
function still give you the same
phenotype
thank you next question we had here was
what about getting individual guides
into the well
and i think that's in reference to that
since this is an array
of pools into a single of a single guys
into for a single gene is there
individual guide options
right okay so for the
lenti array libraries that i showed like
the kinase library
the ones used in the in the last couple
of experiments um
we do pool four up to four
um guides expressing different guides
but targeting the same gene um but if
you want
individuals if you want just a single uh
guide
as a lentiveral construct we can do that
for
custom collections so that way you can
get you know one
or more different guys per gene in
different wells
targeting your genes of interest and
then just to be clear
in the glycerol stock option that i
mentioned
those are always provided as one guide
per well it's only the lentiviral
particles that we ever do
um as a pool
awesome you think you got one or two
more in yeah i know we've had you
talking for
for about an hour now let's let's find
one more
yeah great all right about um
about selection and and delivering
one or both vectors oh yeah i think
that's this one here
okay so let me read this okay yeah so if
you deliver cas9 via one vector and the
guide rna on another vector
is it possible for only one of the
vectors to get into the cell
yeah so of course it's possible um
you know so generally speaking um
it is that's why it's recommended for
screening especially that you would
produce a cas9 stable cell line
certainly the only delivery variable you
have
is um with with that guide rna
but if you do a co-transduction with the
cas9 and the guide
as i said of course it's possible only
one gets in so then you could just do
you know selection with both um of
antibiotic resistance
uh markers um but you may not even need
to do selection at all you might just be
able to directly assay for knockout
um with the assumption that enough of
your cell population
got both the cas9 and the guide and
you're able to see it so some of that's
just going to depend on
the overall efficiency
our final comments here and i just
wanted to say before we go i i want to
thank um
thank you luis for uh for your great
presentation
and thank our audience for joining us
today um as i said in the opening
questions that we did not get time to
answer
or any of those that come in from during
the on-demand period
will be addressed by email that you
provided during your registration
uh we'd like to thank lab roots for
hosting this for us
and thermo fisher scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this can be viewed on demand in the
future lab roots will alert you by email
when this is available for replay
and we encourage you to share that with
your colleagues who have may have missed
today's live event
and with that i want to thank you all
for joining and hope you guys have a
great rest of your day
you